Adam Kilgore joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show how did you find Durant's mom
after the game last night uh I rich
Blind Luck Republic sort of like you
know it's playing at these finals you
know the NBA arena can be like very
congested places especially an event
like the files there's so many media
there's so many friends and family sort
of like a million around postgame and
pregame and so basically I was like
trying to walk my way to the Warriors
locker room and I started looking around
and I see there's Wanda Durant you know
they're the Durant's are from the
Washington area so I don't know family
well but you know it's showing of who
they are what they look like and
everything so I said okay this is a good
chance to say you know first eat things
from her perspective and she was great
enough to share a little bit over time
and so share it with our fans who may
not have read your your material what
what did she say about this shot and and
because we all know that Durant's close
with his family and and and this has
been for somebody who made a decision
that everybody thinks was so easy and it
was easy to succeed with it's been
fraught with no doubt a lot of pressure
no question yeah so two things one about
the shot itself you know it's know it
kind of struck me is like so
representative and in serve like a
crowning moment you know like like
wanted rancid that she sort of thought
back to you know when he was a kid
seven years old and C+ in Maryland you
know watching shots at the activity
center you know that very same shot she
was watching practice of thousands of
times but probably almost millions of
times you know going back to when he was
a kid who serve all those small shots
kind of building this one big shot over
LeBron James the guy who was NBA career
at sort of been the one guy separating
him from being really considered the
best player in the world so it was very
sort of crowning and fitting moment
there and the second thing she said well
I sort of tried to ask her about you
know her perspective on if the series in
that moment sort of you know validates
for Kevin the
decision to come to Golden State and she
didn't premium so she said to basically
no because that decision was validated
the moment he made it
a key footpath thing where he wasn't
looking back he didn't necessarily make
a decision when championship we made
because he wanted opportunity you have
to go to a new and different city with
new and different teammate studies you
know just sort of curious to play was
and see how they could you know change
his game how they could elevate his game
and that whatever happened he was going
to be fully justified
you know outcome aside so that's pretty
good perspective I think it tells you a
lot about who Kevin Durant is - Adam
Kilgore the Honda inside a reporter here
for us on the Rich Eisen show from the
Washington Post and we appreciate him
calling in day after him his coverage of
Game three from Cleveland and so who is
Durant for those who just think he's uh
maybe a carpetbagger and an opportunist
at heart
sure yeah he's a I think it's a pretty
complex character I think well I think
very sort about the core view is he
wants to be liked which probably made
the decision that he made to go go and
say the aftermath really challenging for
him you know certainly hasn't been like
a challenging a basketball experiences
in the NBA files but I think it was a
challenging experience for him starting
from the moment the team I think sort of
fitting his game considering his
personality into the Golden State
Warriors
what was the pretty difficult sub
process for him because he's so gifted
that they sort of need his individual
billions as a scorer to reach the
highest level but his natural tendency
is to I think is to defer you know and
probably that that sort of extends off
the core but certainly in the basketball
sense it means that you know if she's
coming in to new situation he's gonna
he's even got a sort of go absolutely to
not be the guy who sort of dominating
and taking over so sort of finding that
line where the Warriors could exploit
his brilliance as a one-on-one sort of
ice isolation scorer and also sort of
cater to his desire to be selfless
that that sort of balance is sort of you
know in a way to sort of central
storyline of the whole year figure in
and the Warriors to probably and so how
much of what we're seeing right now is a
function of his
surroundings or a function of what Steve
Kerr saying that he's realizing Durant
that this is his moment and he is
grasping it and this is something that
he's now etching in history books yeah I
think I think that he'd realizes I think
he learned over the year that you know
sometimes the selfless thing is just
that you sort of be selfish the thing
that I don't know if it's a dumb way to
phrase it or not but you know that what
specialty team when yours Kim grant is
to is to take over is to be a guy who
will kill all the court of itself
pull up and take a shot at him over
LeBron James to to when they came
through the final I think he realized
that over the course of this season I
think probably when he got injured and
they'd sort of watched how the Warriors
functioned without him nothing they had
a lot of trouble but I think sort of
being will step back sort of process how
he played and how the Warriors played
with him and watch them without him I
think that you know in a weird lights
were probably helped I mean I don't
think you would wish getting hurt by any
means but I do think that it was a
productive sort of period of the season
for him and and for the Warriors to Adam
Kilgore of the Washington Post joining
us here after he spoke with the Durant's
after last night's big Game three Game
three three-point shot from Durant
joining us here in the Honda inside a
report what was it like in the building
last night when that happened uh-oh what
happened it was it was genereal I mean
it was like you gotta be kidding me is
that waving to happened yeah as the
Warriors do I mean if it's that any
structures is so such a you know symbol
of who they are I mean it was okay the
Warriors that the the Cavalier seem to
be pretty comfortably ahead of six often
firing everything going good only like
three minutes left and then it was just
yeah you know okay Curry gets a mismatch
layup
Durant gets a mismatch on Chris Pontius
and Thompson you know easy bank shot
couple of stops they come back down
grants and three all of a sudden is the
Ayers got sucked out of the place it was
rocking all night it was a great
atmosphere you could I think I you know
I sense that both the Cavaliers and
their fans sort of knew that you know
maybe the series is over
by at least staring pathetic games going
to be game three the first game at home
did they lose that one my gosh it can be
really hard to regroup and try to win a
game for down down three Oh on one day's
arrest so I think that was they knew
that was a chance and you know the faces
on the fans locking out of that place
which is crestfallen you know sort of
you know what just happened kind of a
look to him
I don't know you also wrote a piece on
Steve Kerr coming back what what what
what did you learn about curve and how
he was dealing with what he was dealing
for him to get back and coach these last
two games of the NBA Finals that he
already didn't know Adam sure so I think
one thing that sort of stuck out talking
a few people is how difficult this has
been formed physically and not just the
the Ament pain he's in which you know I
can't imagine you know what was like
that that you know has headaches like
that and you know just the phrase quite
a leakage didn't sound too fun but it
also sort of whatever and the Warriors
and people right Amir are not sort of
forthcoming with exactly what he's going
through but it did sound like that he's
going through a lot of sort of later to
rehab or you know a various sort of
medical experiments but you know just
trying to find something that will ease
his pain he's done so much just really
get back at this point you know anything
that stuck out is just how much the
Warriors trust him you know they
basically put the decision in his hands
and trusted him to do what was best for
his health but also best for the team
you know I mean I can't imagine is two
other people other than the Steve Kerr
and Mike Brown who could have made
basically trading team back and forth so
as far as who's coaching the sideline
really a non-issue for a team in the NBA
final which they have in a way like it's
been so smooth that's been almost
overlooked just how remarkable and how
odd it is of a situation it is I think
it's like testament to the culture of
the Warriors and I think Kerr probably
the biggest sort of creator of that
culture
I'd appreciate your reporting throughout
these finals thanks for calling in
appreciate it thanks buck we got it
that's Adam Kilgore of the Washington
Post
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy